the Sequoia memo okay did you read this
no I avoided it on purpose
thanks denial the best the best approach
yeah I we haven't raised venture capital
so it's a little bit different so
Sequoia is one of the biggest venture
capital firms here in Silicon Valley
they are famous for back in 2008 I want
to say they released this presentation
called our IP good times and they
basically they called an emergency
meeting of all their portfolio companies
they invited them to this dinner locked
him in a room put this presentation up
on the screen that was basically like
hey the good times we've all been
experiencing are about to end here's why
most of you entrepreneurs you have not
been a part of these cycles we've been
investors through the dot-com boom and
the bust and then this new boom and this
was right before the sort of financial
crisis of 2008 and they told him look
money is about to become hard to come by
we are going to have a giant financial
crisis it will have ripple down effects
to you guys to your customers to your
clients to your investors and so you
need to start tightening up anything
you're wasting money on you need to stop
wasting it
anything if you haven't raised money if
you don't have 12 months in the bank you
need to go raise money right now to sort
of be able to endure a downturn and they
just released another one which is the
new Sequoia memo so that was 2008 now
they released a new one and they
basically like look this coronavirus
stuff is a this is a once in a hundred
year virus and there's this it happened
in China which is like when you shock
China you shock the global supply chain
and also now that travel is gonna stop a
whole bunch of business is gonna come to
a halt
but stock markets gonna go into a panic
because we've been in a 10-year bull run
and that's about to sort of end anyways
so they told them the same thing change
your spending habits you need to tighten
up raise money if you if you have an
offer out there take it don't worry
about valuation just taking get the
money in the bank and and you know you
need to go into a sort of survival mode
you need to change gears and that's what
just came out which i think is very
interesting have
you made any adjustments to your
business not yet but I live like this
anyway I'm kind of a cockroach in the
first place yeah and I actually think
that me living this way has kind of been
a consequence it has been is hurt me
more than it's helped me actually I
think it made it so I wouldn't spend
enough money which if you have a machine
that turns a dollar into more than one
dollar dump that dump the truck your
money truck like what ad spend or what
do you mean yeah I mean look if you have
a funnel where you are a product where
if you just spend more on marketing or
spend more on engineers or spend more on
content creators and it turns that new
customer into more than what you
acquired them for right then if anyone
had a little machine that turned one
dollar into one dollar one penny the
name of the game is throw as much money
on into that machine as you possibly can
as fast as you can and I've had those
machines and I didn't capitalize on it
and so I've lived this way all the time
and I think it's actually hurt me a lot
but in times like these bring it on
yeah you don't need to adjust we haven't
changed how we've done things just
because we're always tight yeah and your
company's in a good position to like
just now before this we were looking at
a company's P&L and it was like cash in
the bank
220 grand or something like that it's
like do sure a couple months away from
insolvency you know if that is the case
whereas you guys are in a much better
position yes I do I am I do have a
little fear I don't know how I feel
about this Corona thing it when it means
what it means for business I do think
that I'm on the side of I think it's bad
but I don't think it will be as bad as I
think
or as I originally thought right I I
guess I just have faith I have a lot of
blind faith that it will work out
[Music]